hello welcome to see you're playing leo
da and get a King zinan know growing
fault going with the Bishop f4 line see
what happens 94 yeah people still play
that it's not particularly grade still
gets played the thing is that of course
I have forgotten the details rooks III
is a move but you can also take this
check and should be 5 and I think this
is right but it's been a while since I
looked at it
there's a game Karpov Kasparov from the
1986 world championship match where
Kasparov now played e6 and after c6 be
takes g6 Karpov was much better and won
the game I think it was like that but ok
yeah that should be exactly the game I
think it continued age 6 h-4 something
and then f 3 and 9 h three if i'm not
mistaken something like that like it's
got the a porn but white has this
fantastic um protected paso ok I'm going
age for now play play em like carp off I
think couple played it played it in that
way yeah at night h3 and f3 so I'm just
going going on pure yes I copycat mode
so to say ok wants to play Bishop a4 ok
so go rook a1 and prevent that the night
has to go to h3 to allow f3 so that
Bishop to e4 is no longer an idea and
now i can get the night over to the
three this is very similar to the cup of
game to the cup of course power of game
ok g5 a good night f2 we might have g5 I
don't want that maybe rook a true trying
to force the rook trade and then see
about things
check
rook a five maybe hmm now I'm
threatening to take it so he has to
think about it if he wants to go see for
he and possibly be possibly give me the
default Square and some scenarios okay
and one day of c-4 is a move I would get
to enter on see aid I'm not sure about
it
should I was expecting Bishop g5
actually okay I guess I check and just
make some sense what now if I can that
Bishop and go F for it would be great
but not quite sure that I can get this
in the check is not going to be enough i
guess the rube c7 check i mean hmm if i
move the night you might have g5 what I
can try its g5g for it it's very slow
word it might be possible just go for
domination in a way
might be terribly slow actually why
don't I mean should I for check Kingda
too okay some try to run the a pawn and
let's do this first you cannot take 95
is made so nothing's ever going to
happen there and now just bring the
night over or ok it ok it's not bad and
now I can move the night his bishop is
entombed it cannot cannot do anything I
didn't see this beforehand that f3 Hanks
it's not good
okay i can take a form and return some
it's not oh my my rock my rook hmm
probably not such a great square I
wanted to get out of that diagonal and
Kim I think I should have just taken
just taken on f3
95 coming would be pretty strong I think
I mean the rook has to even give up the
same drawing and she'll get several hits
that's if I floor will be decisive I
think
Luke doesn't have any moves
check sometime morning chick cannot
cover the night yes I can do this on as
root before
I take it through let's chat actually
not so not so clear checking politics i
can get you good to be true that's a
move either missed earlier Bishop takes
Bishop takes rook takes check on a HD
seven and I promoting I could have done
that check check and which is so instead
on I Scott rookie to Wow and do I have
to do that check that's off that's awful
really okay check check black forfeits
on time oh ok yeah I think that was a
thick complete copy of that right at the
beginning of that cup of kasparov game
pretty pretty sure I mean if not it's
it's it's awfully close maybe there was
some kind of some I know some moves and
so did but it's very close I wondered
about g5 yeah but he didn't do that g5
jinx possibly am rookie one does an
interesting idea by the engine
funny okay this happen I went age four
check ya around here it gets very good
for white I mean maybe he could have
improved earlier Jan some see if I rc4
is strong yeah that is strong limiting
the the bishop even though one but I
think actually that the engine ok it
gives it climbs am it was unlike 0.6 and
I think this is too low i think white
should be a lot better here with this
Bishop out of the game I mean it can
never enter the game anymore that is
gone check yeah I'm not sure about my
g45 thing I really wanted to make sure
that this Bishop is never doing anything
but in the meantime it costs it costs
time simply so I'm definitely better but
how much this is something something
else ok the engine just does this and
wins yeah I mean he has no meaning for
discovery here and I'm going to see 5 I
came it should have checked something it
would it's like + + 3 check and check
check night 2 p-7 what kind of moves
that ok for d 7 m40 78 yeah that's kind
of an that's understandable yeah only
here I saw that King be to idea here and
okay i can take g7 I wasn't sure I
wasn't really sure ok I'm covering this
set was pretty simple yeah I'm covering
the crucial square yeah that was the
easiest wind going for the exchange up
you chilled chat yeah I mean his in the
game and they had literally had less
time actually it is this particular
moment but he was pretty slow yeah
probably somewhat deserved that victory
even though I could have made it much
clearer with lube takes rook takes g7
okay well thanks for watching